i think the best way to make something
is not thinking about the result but um
just doing it because you feel like you
have to
what does it mean to be bold i think you
said something where you have to be bold
to make it in hollywood what does bold
mean
yeah i'm laughing because
i mean
i can make it in hall it's the
expression that i
i said it but it makes me cringe you
know because make it it's like what is
making it the more time i spend here the
less i know what it means it's like to
get yeah to get paid i guess to do
something you love
um you gotta be bold in the sense that
you gotta put yourself out there and
it's really hard and you know we all
struggle with it
which is
um
sometimes we feel like we're more
comfortable
in a place that's not really comfortable
which is
you know i'd rather not go to that event
or that screening or i'd rather stay
home and watch tv because it's so
hostile and all that and sometimes you
gotta show up
um
you know you gotta send those emails
and the thing with emails or you know
or texts if you have a phone number and
you have a relationship
sometimes they don't you don't get
replies you know
you get rejections people ignore you
they don't get back to you you know
you think you're going to meet and the
meeting gets cancelled
so being bold is
um
being persistent you know being
getting out of your comfort zone because
your comfort zone is not really
comfortable
you think it is i mean i tell this to
myself every day
i think you know i'm a writer what do i
do what i know how to do is to write and
you know well no that's not it because
you can be an amazing writer and no one
will notice
um and it's hard you know learning to
put yourself out there is hard
and sometimes surround yourself with
friends who do it and learn from them
i've
you know i i hate it but i had to teach
myself you know go out to that event
meet people follow up
um
you know
friends that can get you into things
tell them can you get me into that event
you know and and you meet people of
course then you know
you gotta have something to show and all
that
um
be nice to everyone you know invite them
out ask them out for a coffee or drinks
at some point things will start moving
by themselves you know
the other thing i noticed with time no
one likes to read script
so i've been thinking of directing
something myself i'm actually writing
something i want to direct
because people don't like reading but
they like watching
so
even if you don't get into sundance or
whatever
it's something to show
you know
and um
i think the best way to make something
is not thinking about the result but um
just doing it because you feel like you
have to
you know
so
there's not one single way to do it this
is what i'm doing right now
and hopefully it pays off
and i know you said earlier that the
term making it makes you cringe and i
get why that would be but
do you think the longer that you're here
or that we are here in this town
or in the industry that the
term making it the needle moves so it's
like this spectrum and and making it
when you first got here would be one
thing but then after you've been here a
long time you realize no
there's not really a making it because
it's then one project in the to the next
and
that idea of success it just keeps
moving you know there's a carrot that
you can't grab
i think i think it's healthy
to demystify and the the idea
uh
i think it was gertrude stein they used
to say there's no there there
you know in the sense that um
one thing that has been helpful living
here is realizing that
that that i aspire to
is here i mean that
um you know i got a chance to meet in
vegas tom cruise right oh nice
and it was just we were just two guys in
a room sure he's a mega star and
whatever and his you know everything
shines about him but
you know the fact that i can have access
to that guy and he and we can talk
means that it's not a different world
you know
um it's funny when i
back in my country in argentina people
ask me like so what's hollywood like
i'll say
well it's mostly a bunch of people in
offices
you know it's not glamorous sure i mean
you go to the emmys or the oscars or
whatever and they're glamorous but the
rest of the year
it's just a lot of people in office is
saying yes no yes no
do we have the money do we want to spend
the money and then going to shoot
and you know
shooting anything is not glamorous at
all so it takes a long time you know
it takes a lot of waiting
this is the thing no one talks about you
know like movies are glamorous no movies
are not glamorous events are glamorous
shooting a movie is
strenuous it's exhausting it can be
frustrating
[Music]
that's why actors have trailers because
they have to wait
you know you gotta sit up
and then when you're in development your
meeting in office is having coffee
and a lot of times it's just saying no
because it's
from their side the exact side it also
takes
courage you know
saying no is easy you don't waste money
saying yes well
that's where it actually starts
um i don't know i guess we're all here
because we think that it's possible
it's possible to do what we want and get
paid for it it's possible to um
[Music]
make a career out of it
and when you're here the truth is i you
know i think about this often is
i gotta remind myself there are more
things in life than a career i mean of
course i gotta pay a rent and that's a
big concern you know i gotta make a
living
ideally i can have enough money to also
buy other things and
eventually send my kids to college and
all that but um
you know we get so obsessed the whole
the whole struggle here the hustle you
get obsessed with
it's all about work and i'll work 24
hours a day if i have to on weekends
like no what's the point you know
especially if you do something creative
it's really hard to do something
creative if all you're doing is working
you got to find some balance
or try at least i mean if you have no
choice i get it but
it can't all be about work all the time
and making it
it's not sustainable
i see you know i see very young people
who are exhausted
um
again because i want to talk about the
back side as well you know like
people who are actually doing really
well and are stressed out and are
exhausted and are not sleeping like
you're gonna sleep you gotta eat you
know
anyway
when you tell your friends in argentina
that it's hollywood is really a lot of
people in offices what's their reaction
um
[Music]
i guess some people
ignore me because they want to keep
thinking whatever they want to think
people who are in the film industry
there which is
it's barely an industry it's way smaller
i mean there's a lot of production but
i think they find that um interesting
encouraging they're like oh really that
makes sense or they ask me do you go to
the beach and i say rarely i don't you
know i forget there's a beach
you know i'm a writer i'm just
i think it's you know every time you
reveal something um
the backs you know the backstage or
the backflip of uh something people
imagine it's always interesting
nothing you know nothing's as glamorous
or as exciting from the inside
um that's a good point
hopefully the writing itself is exciting
you know
the other thing i always say is a lot of
the times the people in charge the
people have the power don't know what
they want
until they see it
you know so
if you get rejected
it doesn't mean your script is bad or
it does it's not worth it i mean
it's all very subjective
you know
it's very easy to get discouraged when
you get turned down
in contests or fellowships and you're
like oh my god i'm awful i'm not good
enough
maybe you know maybe they they were just
looking for something else
i was a finalist for example i mean one
of nbc's writing programs i was a
finalist and i did really well in that
interview
and i didn't get it and um
they told me it's you know
don't take it too hard themselves they
said you know it's like we had to pick
i don't know six seven people
uh so i didn't i said you know what
i could have been one of them i mean
it's just
it's also a matter of luck and you know
context
this project you want to that you're
writing to direct do you plan on
shooting it here in the states
no i'm actually it's interesting i i'm
writing that to [ __ ] in argentina
for several reasons because i'm i'm
setting it
down there um
and also to be perfectly honest because
the exchange rate is really beneficial
so um if you have dollars right now
you can
you can do whatever you want in
argentina and you know dollars go a long
way again not to imply that i'm going to
exploit my fellow countrymen
because i intend to pay really good
salaries but um
you know it makes a difference
the currency fluctuates a lot there yeah
inflation is a really big inflation
um
but again i mean you can you can get a
an amazing
crew and
equipment and everything and
really qualified people and actors and
um
and it's also a great way for me to
reconnect with my own country i mean
it's not just a financial choice it's
just that i really want to
reconnect with the
yeah with the language and then the
culture and
the stories down there